salut maintenant c'est devenu une
habitude vous savez tous les jours je
vous donne une énigme et le lendemain je
vous donne la réponse et on se fait ça
pendant 32 jours ce sont les énigmes de
l'été hier plus qu'une énigme vous est
donné à défis à résoudre avec les piles
dans les fourches des pouces si vous
n'avez pas vu le défi aller voir d'abord
la vidéo parce que là je donne la
solution tout de suite par rapport à
toutes les contraintes que je vous avais
donné la plupart d'entre vous ont dû se
retrouver bloqué à ce stade là à ce
niveau là en réalité il ya vraiment une
méthode pour les saisir entre pouces et
index sans qu'elle ne se touchent et
sans le tenir pas d'autre part d'autres
dois je vais passer derrière la caméra
et vous allez voir comment ça se passe
on va garder à peu près le même geste
une main parallèle au sol et l'autre
perpendiculaire sauf que lorsqu'on
arrive ici le pousse au lieu de prendre
ici va venir se coller la l'index ici
juste là donc je vous refais le geste
lentement au lieu d'arriver comme ça mon
pouce vient au fond et l'index
ici le pouce droit est bien positionné
l'index va chercher l'autre côté et on
n'a plus qu'à les ressortir c'est très
agaçant pour second des petits problèmes
de motricité mais c'est très amusant à
faire et surtout ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'énigme est aujourd'hui c'est une
énigme d'objets retrouvés l'objet en
question un indice chez vous y a pas d'
indices mais j'avais envie de me prendre
un peu pour julien lepers celui qui me
fabrique mais devant celui qui
m'achètent ne se servira pas de moi est
celui qui se sert de moi ne le sait pas
l'ignorent complètement
qui suis-je vous devez retrouver un
objet suite à cette phrase qui rejoint
toutes ces conditions
celui qui fabrique le vent celui qui me
vent ne se sert pas de moi celui qui se
sert de moi ne le sait pas l'ignorent
complètement
cherchez bien vous pouvez en parler dans
les commentaires si vous avez la bonne
réponse ne l'a dit pas pour que les
autres cherchent donc il faut pas
spolier les autres par contre si vous
avez trouvé mettez un pouce en l'air
comme ça on verra proportionnellement le
nombre de pouces en l'air par rapport au
nombre de vues et donc combien de
personnes on trouve là c'est un très bel
été n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne si ce n'est pas déjà fait voir
même de partager ces petites énigmes
pour ce jeu de l'été il nous reste
encore vingt jours comme ça puisque moi
aussi je vous rappelle la shoah train de
prendre des vacances au moment où ces
vidéos sont diffusées
et sinon le mental joue ici une vidéo
par jour pendant un an donc rendez vous
demain à 10
touch à eau